let's go to our caller from the 8th 1/3
area code who's calling today from 8 1 3
hello yes that's you hey David I'm
calling to ask if you think that is
gonna be a rift forming in the
Democratic Party especially in regards
to the next debate between people like
Yankelovich are gathered and sort of
identitarian like we will including
Castro's talk about you know giving
abortions for free to you know many
thing for women sorry what are you
talking about if you think there's going
to be a rift or some kind of no I heard
what do you who Leon Castro is an
identity what's in identitarian first of
all I should have said identitarian it's
not their own identities that they're
concerned with this it's it's a lot of
their platform has to do with I didn't
he's a lot of the rhetoric has to do
with that identity okay
and Julio Castro wants biological men to
have abortions how does that work
medically he's talked he talked about
providing abortions or he's at least he
talked about transgender women in
regards to free health care and
providing you know free abortions to
them how does someone without a uterus
have an abortion
that's my question okay that I've not
heard that brought up and it I can't
imagine that that's really a serious
issue in the 2020 Democratic primary
well that was just at that point is
that's really my new said that was just
like it's exemplified kind of kind of
what I mean by by by people who embrace
identity and who's ready to come through
with identity the real question is do
you see a risk forming between Yang and
some people who are moderate like a bird
or or Klobuchar a risk born between them
and people who largely talk about
identity no I don't I don't see a rift
forming along those lines and also most
of the candidates you mentioned are
going to be gone by the third debate so
I think they're gonna be non factors in
like three weeks yeah the really key one
they're young yeah I mean Yang Gabbard
and Klobuchar are there and Castro quite
frankly is on the fringes there I don't
know that they're gonna make it
beyond the second debate so I don't
think we're gonna hear that much more
from them pretty soon mm-hmm and you
don't see you don't see people kind of
going after Yang especially if he gains
more popularity for for not really
embracing like like like really ubi is
it goes against a lot the identitarian
stuff because it's it's it's for all
Americans what do you mean by
identitarian I'm I mean maybe I'm using
the wrong word identitarian but I mean
people like like like the thing you were
talking about earlier how common-law
harris use billy use that that that
whole busing thing as as a club you know
to bash over the head of joe biden and
also i'm gonna be totally honest with
you I think that you've got a reframe
your understanding of the Democratic
primary because I think you're you're
digging in niches that are completely
fruitless and I I would just kind of
like rethink my understanding of the
slate of candidates before I go any
further appreciate the phone call though
great to hear from you that's it for
calls today thanks to everybody who
called and we will take calls again